voilà plusieurs mois que les habitants
de frégate est de n'avait pas vu la mère
de cyprès dans ce quartier les sargasses
s'accumulent depuis des années la
dernière invasion a fait monter en
flèche le taux d'hydrogène sulfuré
las d'attendre les interventions des
pouvoirs publics les riverains ont
finalement trouvé une solution eux-mêmes
le barrage il a quatre jours d'existence
donc actuel membre de sos en cours de
mise au point avec le marin pêcheur
qu'il a réalisé et nous avions rêvé
décidé cela après une rapide
consultation il ya grosso modo 15 jours
et vous voyez qu'aucun jours on a réunit
l'essentiel du financement et nous avons
fait face le marin pêcheur qui arrive ça
est en cours de réglage installé sur
toute la baie le fil et peut être
décrocher pour permettre le passage des
bateaux
il a coûté 25 mille euros le concepteur
c'est lui alexis de jaham son idée
rappelle le fils est installée au robert
celui ci cependant ne dévie pas les
sargasses il les pièges
quand les sargasses s'entassent dessus
elle s'étouffe ça se voit très bien
d'ailleurs
vous commencez à voir les petits trous
et de l'eau à paraître au ras du filet
ce sont les crs qui commence à couler
à partir du moment où elle coule eh ben
elle en voit beaucoup moins ceux de deux
ans puisque l'eau se régénère avec les
marées montantes et descendantes et
selon la forme de la baie avec les
courants qui passe pour les riverains
qui ne peuvent débourser une telle somme
les communes pourraient passer commandes
le dispositif pourrait même être
installé en plein air pour faire des nas
sargasses pour l'instant vous voyez un
filet qui coûte y est on peut utiliser
tout à fait plus au large
ce sont le lait problème c'est après ce
sont comment les fixer au large avec un
système de mouillage avec le système de
combos ou bien des pylônes gros con con
mais dans les belles mais vous voyez la
distance entre le dernier point la tâche
et le rivage il ya au moins 80 m donc en
mettant un point de mouillage environ
sous les 50 ou 80 m ça devrait marcher
des pontons
faute d'un financement de l'état les
promoteurs et utilisateurs espère
obtenir une défiscalisation du
dispositif quant aux tapis de sargasses
vieux de plusieurs années la préfecture
qui s'était engagé à l'enlever a
commencé à tenir parole et devrait venir
terminer la semaine prochaine